WITH THE LEAFSKYROU WITH A SHOT.
REBOBO THE
TAPE OF PAVEL BUCHNEVICH WHO HAS
BEEN O BORTUZZO ONE
EARLIER.
>> John: SPACE STRIDE.
THOMAS, TO THE GOAL WITHKYROU.
HANDS IT OFF FOR BUCHNEVICH ON A
BACKHAND, GETS IT
MUZZIN, TAKES THE SHOT, HUSSO
THE SAVE AND THE REBOUND.IT'S'S
HID, BOZAK, KOSTIN IN, SCORES!T.
FOR NYLANDER.
BACK IN FRONT, CHANCE FOR
KERFOOT, AND HUSSO OUT AT THETH
THROUGH.
TURNED OVER, KYROU IN TIGHT, ANY
TIME, AS A RIGHTHANDED SHOT. KY
NIGHT AND WE'RE TIED AT TWO!
[N CAUSING A
LITTLE BIT OF A SCREORES!
BRAYDEN SCHENN WITH HIS 100TH
GOAL WITH THE ST. LOUIS BLUES,
CAMPBELL.
WHAT A GREAT PLAY BY FAULK,
THOUGH, TO JUMP UP ANDND
ANYONE.
MATTHEWS DOWN THE WING, CHECKED
BY FAULK, GOT IT OFF TIC TAC TO
BRANDON SAAD 2020 SHOT HERE
FROM PERRON, AND MORGAN
RIELLY WAITS, SHOOTS, ANDOLL GO
AFTER IT.
BUMPED BYA STICK ON THE WAY ANDS
HAVE JUMPED OUT 5-3
>> Cra HE'S
GOING TO GET IT OFF HIS PAD
BUCHNEVICH, SCORES!
PAVEL BUCHNEVICH KNOCKS IT IN TO
THEEUST
CHIPPED IT TO